[Music]
6 26 on your wednesday morning you know
it's been a minute since we checked in
up on that big project at the 95 in the
northern 215 beltway are you ready let's
go
centennial board
how about that been a while okay so the
nevada department of transportation they
are doing a complete overnight closure
of the sapphire 95 at the 215 this week
but you have to freak out for a couple
of reasons first it is only during the
overnight hours and it's pretty easy
work around the hours well it started at
eight last night ran till five this
morning but they're doing it again
tonight and tomorrow night so drivers on
the south 95 you cannot go through under
the beltway but the detour is pretty
easy they take you on to the west 215
over to durango right you hop across the
freeway to centennial parkway then it's
a short hop to the 95 south ramp and
you're on your way closures there for
work on the new bridges there in the
centennial bowl ndot still looking at
wrapping everything up there
in 2024.
we do have a link to everything you need
to know about the project at
eightnewsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
you can join the driving you
conversation driving you crazy
conversation with traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com